hey you guys
we're doing another movie retrospective
and we're talking about another
vincent price classic in fact
vincent price has said on numerous
occasions that this was actually
probably his favorite role that he ever
did
in all of the movies that he was in and
he was in like 100 and something movies
like just a ridiculous amount yeah it's
strange this isn't his best movie in my
opinion
it's you know what though this one is a
lot of fun
actually i kind of feel like it's a lot
of fun it's kind of like a remake of
that was that dr phebes
the abominable doctor vibes i guess it's
fives it's similar to that
yeah which came out a couple years
before this one yeah and a lot of people
have said that too but this one is much
more
much campier much more overtly comedic
and also much gorier i remember i
remember dr fives being category but
this one is like
way way way gorier dr fives had a little
bit more of a
better color palette it was a little
more extravagant
higher budget but i can see how he would
like this one though i mean it's a
little more it's like i said it's funny
but it's more almost like a slasher oh
yeah big flashers type
uh gore effects i was actually surprised
by how gory this was
yeah it's kind of sardonic you know
yeah it's definitely like a rule it's
definitely a black comedy and it's
definitely kind of like
but yeah so this is called theater of
blood um
dermot one of our uh british patrons
uh actually sent me an amazon gift card
to purchase this with he was also the
same guy that sent
the money for brimston and treacle which
we also reviewed so we're finally
getting around to
talking about this one and i think the
blu-ray that i bought also has
another i think it's another vincent
price movie from whisper to a scream on
it so we might end up doing that one
eventually as well but like i said so
this one comes out in 1973
and it's directed by douglas hickox
and stars i mean pretty much all of your
british big british character actors at
the time
were in this [ __ ] movie i mean it's
like a who's who
of this time period and a lot of like
classical actors and stuff
but the main part of vincent price he's
the main guy and then
his daughter edwina is played by diana
rigg
uh you know from avengers yeah so uh and
among zillions of other things because
it wasn't she was in a bond movie too
right she wasn't she um
in on her majesty's secret service i
kind of felt like see that one
i kind of feel like she was probably in
that this also has diana doors in it
like i think
this was kind of like past her heyday i
suppose but she's just like in one scene
i think where she's getting
where she's getting a massage that looks
like sex with vincent price
it's a long story this is the only
this is the only story this is the only
movie i've ever seen where
vincent price pretended to be gay
he does a really good
it's like a disguise he puts on yeah one
of many
he goes into like his 70s cool dude
outfit with a big old fro
the gold perm on his head and he's got
his daughter dressed up like a boyfriend
and they just pretend to be a gay couple
and [ __ ] and he's [ __ ] awesome this
game and
you just have to see it to believe it
you're like wait this is vincent price
right he's just being gay as hell
i it works so you can tell that he was
just having the time of the [ __ ] life
making this movie
he was having fun he said well he got to
he got to play all these roles he's
playing a serial
a actor serial killer a shakespearean
actor
and you know he whoever gives him a bad
review he's going to kill you
and he's going to be he's going to be
impersonating somebody else when he does
because he's an actor so he's going to
kill you with his acting and in one n1
in one dear one murder he dresses up as
a gay dude
from a gay couple you could tell he's
having fun with the whole movie
yeah and like i said i think that's why
i mean both him and diana riggs said
this was like one of their favorite
roles and i mean vincent prices was his
favorite movie they ever did because
i think what the thing with vincent
price was that even i mean he had a long
and storied career people still talk
about him
to this day i mean he was working up
until he was real
very very old you know he was in like
tim burton movies and stuff like he was
in edward scissorhands and stuff
and but i do kind of feel like that
i think that he got a little bit
typecast
and being in all these kind of like b
horror movies yeah um
which i don't think he minded at all
that much but he's always the same in
all of them i think that he kind of
wanted to
maybe be like more of like a
shakespearean actor
um and so maybe that's why this was so
fun for him because he got to play like
all these different he got to do like
all these like flowery soliloquies
and he got to just totally [ __ ] chew
the scenery and ham it up
i think like one of the one of my the
lines that i laughed at the most in this
was like he was reading
because before he'd kill each of the
critics he would read the you know the
bad review that they had given
to him and one of the reviews like
compared him to like a ham sandwich
which i thought was like
which made me laugh really hard well
because it was like a lot more
it was a lot funnier than that because
it was like this big complicated like
setup like because he was between two
good actresses
and then he was in the middle and so it
was like a ham sandwich you know what i
mean
so that like made me laugh yeah i could
see why he he liked this movie the best
yeah i mean big time he he got to play
probably about 30 different roles
yeah and he got to all the costumes and
like i said he got to do all the famous
so you know [ __ ] from all the
shakespeare plays and he got to kill
people in horrible like
increasingly gruesome ways which like i
said what's what's not to love about
that
he gets to play a cop and kills a dude
with some bombs
[Music]
he gets to play a [ __ ] celebrity chef
and
and makes a dude eat his own dogs and
then kill him with his own dogs
[Laughter]
yeah he [ __ ] dresses up as a gay dude
kills
kills uh it was a woman it was a dude
wasn't it no i was a woman who's a woman
yeah how did he how did he kill her i
forgot he electrocuted her in the
in the hairdresser the dryer that's
right yeah that's a hairdresser
there was a guy with him there was a guy
whether that was a cop yeah
yeah he's flirting with the cop you need
a big boy and it's just [ __ ] funny
you know see
vincent price check with an afro and
massive smoked sunglasses yeah it is
leisure suit and [ __ ]
it was a shirt that had like a bunch of
naked greek dudes on yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's right
because i saw the photo and i was
looking for the stills earlier i'm like
oh my god that shirt's fantastic
he was just having the [ __ ] you like
i said you could tell him some of the
time of his life
yeah so like i said now a lot of people
said yeah this is like a gory or campier
version of the abominable dr
fives now i've seen i watched like a lot
of different horror reviews of this some
people like dr fibes better
some people like this one better um i
don't know it's like i kind of feel like
i can
i can see the arguments on both sides
because dr fibes had much more of that
like
brightly colored like this visuals this
one was kind of shot at real locations
uh around london much most of which are
not there anymore obviously
like the theater where they shot it that
was a real theater uh and then
it was torn down shortly after and now
there's houses there or whatever
but so this is much more like a time
capsule of
london in that time period because they
shot it all at real places
uh you know nothing was a set as far as
i know so that's kind of different from
dr fives but like i said it's very much
like the same
kind of story because dr fibes that was
like what was it the
plagues of egypt right that was what the
theme was
yeah that's right um whereas this one
he's killing people
like have to having to do with like how
characters got murdered in shakespeare
plays
yeah um which and i feel like you know
the movie seven the dave adventure movie
i feel like this kind of
like this kind of like maybe was uh a
big
influence for that i know that's like a
weird thing to say because the movies
are completely different because like i
said this is very much
a comedy it's a horror comedy it's gross
it's gruesome
but it's very very much played for
comedy this is like um
um like a prototype of like you know
evil dead and stuff you know i mean
where you're you're mixing humor
and and and horror together you know i
mean
it's that kind of town yeah and dead
seriously yeah and i think that's what
it's not as zany as that
exactly but in a different way but
yeah it's zany but understated zany
yeah so pretty much okay so what the
story behind this is
is uh vincent price plays a dude with
the very
regal fantastic name of edward kendall
sheridan lionheart yeah and he's saying
i know i love it and i love that his
daughter's name his daughter's played by
diana rigg
and his daughter's name is edwina like
he loved himself so much that he had to
name her
after himself you know what i mean i
thought that was really funny
so funny now you're talking more about
it
i had to see it again yeah i mean this
is it's like
there's like some really funny [ __ ] in
there visually i'm gonna give it to dr
fives but
maybe you're right this one might have
been funnier i think this was funnier
than dr vibes
but it was trying to be was trying to be
funnier yeah it wasn't as visual
not a cinematic you know it wasn't
someone you know it wasn't as theatrical
in in that sense you know what i mean
but the acting
and the story and the weird [ __ ] that
happens there's a lot it's a lot more
detailed
yeah yeah yeah it definitely it's a lot
more detailed
it feels newer vibes was kind of like it
had a lot of 60s in it
early 60s kind of yeah and this one like
i said probably because most of it was
shot on location was much more like a
you know like london in the 70s type of
movie
so so he's this actor and
he's a shakespearean actor now it's sort
of left to your imagination whether he's
actually a bad actor and all the critics
are just being [ __ ] to him because
that's all he'll do is shakespeare
um or if he's actually just really
like a shitty actor and there and the
critics are completely
correct in their assessments um but
that's neither here nor there
so what ends up happening is that he
doesn't get this
award from the critics guild or circle
or whatever it is that he thinks he
deserves and they give it to this other
young guy and he gets really pissed off
about it
so this doesn't happen in the beginning
of the movie you don't find this out
until later because there's like a
flashback scene like after pretty much
all the other critics are dead and like
just
the one remaining is kind of telling the
cops what happened so he's like
basically vincent price
or lionheart rather like shows up at our
meeting that we had like
our self-congratulatory circle jerk we
were talking about how cool we were for
giving that award to somebody
and he shows up and he says i should get
that and he tries to take it and they
kind of get all over his case about it
and he
uh gives the to be or not to be speech
from hamlet
and jumps off the balcony now
what ends up happening like so everybody
thinks he's dead much like an
abominable doctor fives where everybody
thinks he's dead and he's killing people
and then they find out later that he
lived and that's kind of what happened
here i thought the first time because
this is the first time i've actually
seen this movie
so we were watching it i thought that he
had done that on purpose
like he staged a suicide um because the
daughter was there and she was screaming
her head off and i was like oh she's in
on it and [ __ ]
so i thought that he staged it so he
could come back and kill them
deliberately but as it turns out he was
actually trying to commit suicide it
just so happened
that he landed in the thames and he
lived and he got saved by a bunch of
hobos
and then the hobos become like a bomb
army
and they'd be and he basically uses them
as like his henchmen
i guess he just keeps them in booze and
they're just like whatever man like they
don't care
i think they're like maybe a bunch of
actors too or they were like a down on
their luck actors because i guess they
were all like squatting in that theater
yeah right so that's what ends up
happening is that
so the first critic he's kind of called
by
a policeman quote unquote to go to this
building that he owns or he's the head
of the
whatever and they're like yeah there's
all these bombs that are squatting in
there and you need to come in there and
get them out
and then so he comes there and it turns
out that these are you know vincent
price's bum army
and they all beat the should beat him to
death much like in a clockwork orange
uh you know what i mean and uh then and
then vincent price like comes up tonight
he's like dressed like a cop
so that's how that whole situation uh
went but every single murder that's in
this
is has um you know a counterpart like
from a shakespeare play and he's doing
them in the order
that he did like his final season you
know
acting season like so he's doing them in
order of like all these uh all the
shakespeare plays that he did
right so the first one so like the
murder from the homeless people that was
kind of um based off you know caesar
getting murdered from julius caesar uh
then there's a second guy this was
probably like one of the one of the most
gruesome ones
hector snipe and he this was from
uh troilus and cressida i think so he
gets stabbed with a spear
and then where when everybody's at the
funeral of the first dude
um i guess vincent price had tied this
dude to a horse's tail and the horse was
like dragging the body behind like at
the cemetery you know i mean so that
happened in trellis and cressida so that
was the second one and then the third
one
which i think was maybe my favorite was
when this old guy
and they get him and his uh wife they
get back to the apartment
and then there's like this massive trunk
in there and they're just like where the
[ __ ] did this come from it's like i
don't know it got delivered let's deal
with it tomorrow i don't know what the
[ __ ] it is
so they both go to bed and it turns out
it will shock no one that vincent price
is in the trunk
and he comes out him and his daughter
who is
helping him even though for the first
half of the movie she's dressed up like
in this ridiculous paul williams from
phantom of the paradise except with
curly hair kind of
vibe look like she's dressed up like a
hippie dude but it's
pretty clearly her you know what i'm
saying yeah not really a hippie
it was seven yeah more kind of like one
of the one of the members of nazareth
or some [ __ ] like yeah yeah that's kind
of what the overheat was yeah they might
mess with fur trim on it and bell
bottoms and
big a big curly frog
a big stupid ridiculous like porn stash
you're right
that type of thing yeah he would have
been kind of like a
like a rocker of that time i guess so
yeah i was trying to think of like who
the
nazareth or molly hatchet
[Laughter]
but yeah so that one so they both pop
out of this giant trunk
and they have all of this you know these
drugs like in a
syringe and the dude like the critic is
sleeping in bed next to his wife
and they pretty much like stick the
syringe in her butt like to make her
fall asleep
and then they have this big [ __ ]
rubber sheet and they put it around this
dude and they just proceed to surgically
like cut his head off
like while the wife is sleeping there
they're cutting the head off and the
wife keeps going stop snoring and it's
like you know
so like i said this is a comedy and then
they leave the head like on the milk
bottle in front of the other one of the
other uh
critics kind of things but i guess that
was from uh cymbeline
right because like somebody finds their
husband's head in bed next to them or
something like that
and then there's the next one is the guy
that gets his heart cut out
that was kind of like the pound of flesh
thing uh [ __ ] doing that in merchant
of venice
uh then a dude gets drowned in a barrel
of wine
that was like from richard iii and then
uh
in one of the most ridiculous and yet
still awesome scenes
he attempts with one of the critics that
actually ends up living till the end
because he's kind of the hero even
though i don't know if i'd call him that
but that dude's name is devlin and he's
reenacting the fencing scene from romeo
and juliet
so they're in this gymnasium and they're
fencing and they're all there's all this
like gymnastic equipment and
trampolines and stuff and they're
fencing and jumping up and down
the trampolines and like slashing at
each other and stuff
it's like so [ __ ] hilarious again i
laughed my [ __ ]
ass off at that as well and then one of
the other guys
he um he pretends that he's a massage
guy and he goes to this other critic's
house and like massages the wife but in
a way that makes it look like he's
[ __ ] her
because he knows that her husband is
super jealous
and that he'll end up killing her and
then he'll go to prison and he'll die in
prison so that kind of works out the way
he wants it to be
which is kind of nice and then the
critic that we were talking about before
that gets uh where he dresses up like
like the campy gay dude and uh puts that
woman in the chair
like in the in the dryer and
electrocutes her
electrocutes her i think that's supposed
to be um from like jo like joan of arc
you know what i mean
uh that was from henry the sixth that
play
interestingly the woman that got
electrocuted like one of the
critics that was coral brown
and vincent price and coral brown met on
this movie and they got married like a
year later
vincent price was already married when
he uh when he met her but i guess he
fell in love with her and then he
divorced his other wife
like his he he was married three times i
think but um
he was married to coral brown i think
she died in the 90s and so he was
married
until she died but then the wife
previous was
they were married for 23 years and i
guess he met carl brown and he's like
yeah bye
but yeah that's how that worked out and
then in probably the most upsetting uh
killing you got the one dude who's like
this super super flamboyant
uh guy he's like got all the pink suits
and everything
and for the whole movie he's been
carrying arthur of the movie yeah he
definitely is
and like for the whole thing he's been
carrying on these two like little
poodles like his babies that's what he
calls them
and uh because in shakespeare's most
hardcore and [ __ ] up and gory play
titus andronicus
there's a scene where one of the
characters eats her own babies
in a pie so guess what happens to these
poor little poodles
yeah they get cooked and put into a pie
and he eats them not really knowing it's
the dog and then
they basically i mean at this point like
don't they make it like it's like a
cooking show yeah like it yeah
like it's a cooking show and he's like
oh we're making you this thing we made
you this pie you can't tell us the dogs
they just reveal it later
and then they do kind of like where they
start forcing food
down his throat yeah they stuff it yeah
which again that kind of reminded me of
seven see i think maybe that's where
they got the idea for seven where that
she's like
making that guy eat everything it would
be easy to see how
movies like this would went on to like
uh like i said inspire seven
yeah yeah i mean it's because it's the
same
formula where it's like a serial killer
that's basically taking hey i'm gonna
kill people
in the manner of yada yada like i said
so you know dr fives it was
plagues of egypt this one it's
shakespeare plays and then in seven it
was seven deadly sins which i'm amazed
nobody actually ever thought of
not that i know of but yeah so devlin
the last one
uh the last critic he gets kidnapped and
they're gonna put his eyes out
uh you know like king lear so but they
have this whole contraption like set up
or whatever
and um so it turns out that i think at
this point
because it's funny there's like a bunch
of cops kind of falling right because
they don't really
twig on to the fact that uh that
lionheart is still alive because he's
got like a whole big [ __ ]
memorial grave and everything like that
so for a while i think they're thinking
that the daughter
is the one doing it this isn't like it's
not super clearly delineated
but i think that the cops are like
suspicious of the daughter which i guess
they have a right to be because she is
helping him
so like she'll wear disguises and like
lure people to various places where they
get
horribly murdered and stuff so but how
that ends up happening so she's the one
that lures devlin back to this thing and
they're doing king lear like i said
they're gonna put his eyeballs out
but then like the contraption gets stuck
and then it turns out that like vincent
price just ends up burning the whole
[ __ ] place down which actually looked
real which well like i said i think that
building that they filmed it in
i can't remember the name of it was the
putney hippodrome or something like that
like it was an old abandoned theater
that they shot in
and i think that they were going to tear
that down anyway
so maybe they just told them hey burn it
down we don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean because at the end
it really did kind of look like they
were burning the [ __ ] down
but so the end is very like king lear
because the daughter gets killed and he
ends up like burning the [ __ ] [ __ ]
down and then he like falls off the
[ __ ]
top or he crashes through the ceiling or
whatever
so there's that kind of whole thing
going on but yeah this is
if you really liked um you know
dr fives what you wanted to see
something that was funnier
gorier and also like
more in a modern setting i guess if you
want to say that because
i mean dr fibes wasn't said a long time
ago it was just more of like a fantasy
type setting i guess dr fives really
reminded me a lot of uh
phantom of the paradise which is i don't
know if you guys ever seen it it was an
old rock opera
it kind of had it kind of had a
fantastical
color palette to it yeah bright you know
uh
it's it's trip it's psychedelic yeah you
know
so i would give it i would give it to dr
fives visually
but this one is real close it competes
with it in a different way
uh it's it's more about story
acting humor the dialogue and stuff
you have vincent price just acting
[ __ ] crazy
to the whole thing like i said you can
tell he is having a [ __ ] ball with
this because he gets to play
all these different like shakespearean
roles he gets to wear all these crazy
costumes and outfits and he just gets to
like [ __ ]
they probably told him to like vincent
just [ __ ] go to town
right and he did and he looks like he's
just having a [ __ ] ball i'd probably
put him on par with each other
yeah they're just different they're
different it's like you know the stories
are very similar i think even in dr
fives he had like a young woman that was
helping him out right
so yeah it's a very very similar concept
i was going like this is like dr five
yeah and well you know everybody pretty
much they knew that too while they were
doing it
yeah and some people i was watching uh
one of my favorite horror uh
guys who's like a british dude named
grumpy andrew who's actually not grumpy
he's actually a lovely person
but uh he does a lot of british war
because he's british and he was talking
about this and he said that he kind of
considers this
because they did make a sequel to dr
fives called dr fives rides again or
doctor
he does something again dr barnes does
something again
yeah that's what it's called but he said
he considered this like the third dr
phibes movie he's like i kind of feel
like this is in the same universe
um you know even though because like i
said it's the same concept but they're
just coming at it from a slightly
different angle
and like i said it's much more overtly
comedic
and campy and they basically were just
like
you know just go crazy with it and they
just went crazy with the gore
i was actually shocked at i mean it you
know it's not like [ __ ]
you know a [ __ ] torture porn it's not
like hostile or anything like that but
for 1973 and for a vincent price movie
it was much gorier than i was expecting
it was much more violent than i was
expecting this [ __ ] would have been
unacceptable in 73. you would then i
mean yeah
it's like pretty over there just got
away with it because it was funny
yeah yeah because it was so over the top
yeah it's just like i mean you know [ __ ]
he's like at one point vincent price
like pulls this dude's heart out and
he's like sitting there holding her it's
like steaming and struggling
it's like [ __ ] crazy i think just
vincent price alone
helped them get away with that [ __ ] yeah
because i i because he was well
respected he classes up the joy he
classes up pretty much any movie he's in
um so they were just like ah it's been
some price you know
he can do it we'll let it slide he can
do whatever he wants to
and like i said because it was so
obviously
funny um you know i think that it's like
although it is kind of like a weird
tonally i guess because some of the
violence is like especially like when
that guy got dragged in like on the
horse's tail i was like holy [ __ ]
i didn't think they'd go that far but
you know what i mean it's it's that kind
of thing but it's still like
that wasn't funny that was like pretty
gory but yeah i'm sure it was cutting
edge in 73
it probably was i'm sure it was but yeah
i mean seriously
if you're i was watching this one
channel too that had
he was doing all of vincent price's
horror movies
like i guess he just did all of them
like subsequently like an order
and uh he was saying that this was
actually probably his favorite one
um which i don't think i'd say that i
think probably mask of the red death is
my favorite one
i don't know man there's so many like
house of usher and all the poe ones are
great
all the [ __ ] pretty much everything
he was in is [ __ ] great
but this is a real real good one and
like i said some of the gags in this
just made me [ __ ] laugh out loud
and for for no other reason than to be
able to see vincent price dressed up as
like the campiest gayest gay that you've
ever seen like with a [ __ ] afro
that's what i was thinking i was
thinking for 73
even though 73 was a lot more permissive
than people think it is especially young
people they don't realize how [ __ ]
wild the 70s were
still that was that was pushing it for
vincent price because vincent price had
been around for a long time
and people might have assumed that
vincent price might have been a stuffy
about [ __ ] like that no
not at all no [ __ ] he'd been in show
business a long time he knew all the
gays
you know i mean they didn't bother him
he went up there and being gay as he
gazed he could beat
those characters and he wasn't you know
there there there was other gay cast
members he wasn't you know
you know being insulting or anything he
was just
he was camping in and off thick yeah he
was butch
it was good yeah there's this hunk of
man
[Laughter]
i didn't notice that the shirt was
[ __ ] greco dudes
something it was something like that it
was like naked dudes they could do or
dudes in loincloths or something like
that i have a picture of it there was
like there was a naked dude on the back
and then there was a naked boot
dude here like on the breastplate and
maybe one on the other side too i can't
really remember it
it was white but it had like all this
kind of artwork on it i kind of i just
got the feeling that it was like
wreck-a-robin
but yeah it was super super fun i think
it's on uh it's on amazon prime i think
you can rent it for 299 399 something
like that
like i said we got the blu-ray uh so
thank you dermot for sending me the
amazon
uh gift card that i used to order this
with
uh because he recommended that we do
this movie so finally we're getting
around to it so
thanks again dermot but yeah if you look
if you dig vincent price and want to see
something funny and gory that's kind of
like dr fives but a little bit different
then definitely uh check this one out
because it's pretty [ __ ]
uh awesome and it's super fun and super
entertaining so
we will see you guys on the next one bye